the Marvel Cinematic Universe just got a
whole lot smaller the release of the
First full trailer for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania is here but say goodbye
to that light-hearted tone from the
first two Ant-Man movies starring Paul
Rhoda Scott Lang AKA Ant-Man and
Evangeline Lilly as hope Van Dyne AKA
The Wasp this latest entry in the MCU
depicts a size shifting team returning
to the quantum realm after Cassie Lang
accidentally opens a rift to the realm
and drags them all in wait wait a minute
you're sending a signal down to the
quantum Realm
turn it off also along for the ride are
the previous Ant-Man and the WASP Dr
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne both of whom
are probably dreaming of superhero
retirement by this point unfortunately
for Our Heroes it seems as though the
quantum Zone has its own array of
inhabitants including Bill Murray whose
role is as yet a mystery and the variant
of Kang the Conqueror the mcu's newest
big body oh a quick aside we're calling
him a variant because Kang's whole deal
is that the Marvel Multiverse is
drowning in Kang's almost all of whom
seem to be a kind of tyrannical warlord
before this trailer would only seen Kang
in a Disney plus series Loki where the
variant was a relatively peaceful fellow
at the end of the world now with Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania showcasing just
how intimidating can the Conqueror can
truly be fans are eager to share their
opinions about The Green Cloud Menace
one user reacted to the trailer on
Twitter by saying CGI is on point also
Kanga looks sick can't wait to see him
rise Ant-Man another poster Charming the
hope for responded by saying Kang is
going to be the best Marvel villain less
hopeful another user retweeted the new
poster for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania which to fix Kang holding the tiny
Heroes atop his middle finger like
breadcrumbs saying I've got a horrible
feeling Kang is going to k word Scott
[Applause]
a pretty common theory by the way the
motion that Kang will be this brutally
merciless killer is so prevalent that
some Outlets are practically pre-written
obituaries for Scott Lang it wouldn't be
out of nowhere every time a new major
villain is introduced in the MCU they
have to make a noticeable first
impression somehow for comparison the
Mad Titan Thanos killed Loki and
Heimdall in his first bout Against The
Avengers there's just no way that
everyone in antsman in the WASP Quantum
Mania is making it out alive one Twitter
user predicted an entire multi-movie Arc
for the conflict with Kang saying I can
see every movie Kang is in ending with
some source of defeat and then another
gang variance just popping in and they
back to square one that would be sick a
never-ending cycle
feels like a fresh start a recent
feature for Men's Health gives us a
pretty good look at the mentality that
Jonathan Majors is taking in his
approach to portraying Kang the
interview reminds us that Mages as well
known for immersing himself within a
role bringing both an intense work ethic
and even more intense energy to his work
when discussing his all-in approach
Majors said I have a tremendous amount
of faith in my preparation and faith in
something greater than me and not
because my ego tells me I am but because
I'm ready crucially for a superhero
movie he boasted I know I can take my
shirt off the actor went on to describe
how he'd run countless miles abstained
from carbs and put his body on the line
honing his physique to the bare minimum
of what comic book audiences expect of
their fearsome villains he also
discussed how he worked with his
strength conditioning coach specifically
to create an imposing figure for Kang
already there's at least one major movie
on the horizon set to Center on Kanga
after Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
with the help of Mages and his Fitness
coaches we're sure audiences will be
gladly fearing all the variations of
this imposing figure for years to come
[Music]